Murph is a great kid she's really bright
but she's been having a little trouble
lately she brought this in to show the
other students the section on the lunar
landings
yeah and it's on my old xbox she always
loved the pictures it's an old federal
textbook we've replaced them with the
corrected versions pretty great oh jeez
we're not gonna kidnap anyone come on
this guy's a master business prick he's
at the top of his game we need to figure
out boy look what we got
brilliant move skipper but now we seem
to meet outside the play lap caddy got
caught up in the moment well hindsight's
20/20 okay come on and here to shed a
little light on the subject for us is a
very special guest please welcome mr.
Peeta Mellark
Peter a lot of people feel as though
they are in the dark yeah yeah I know
they feel now so set the stage for us
talk us through what really happened on
that final and controversial night well
first off you have to have to understand
that when you're in the games you only
get one wish it's very costly